Okay.
Should be live here.
Hello folks.
We're going to taper back up into some
real research here a little bit. Now,
this is really the only day I have to do
this. Potentially a little bit of time,
Tuesday, Wednesday, but I got some
business to do and I am flying out later
next week. Got some things to set up for
that.
But we're going to start getting a
little bit more into real research. Um,
see if we can get in, you know, two,
three solid hours worth of work on this.
Now, with the stuff I've been doing
lately,
it's uh, it's pretty dependent on just
the pure experiments. I'm going to see
how I'm feeling today,
and we're going to go from there.
All
right. So,
I set up 13 GPUs worth of experiments
yesterday. That is what I did.
We've got
We got this box.
Then we got
two tiny boxes.
I think we're just going to go through
these
one at a time.
I do have to get the port forwarding
stuff right though.
Hello, Aaron.
13 experiments. It's actually like a
couple thousand experiments. It's 13
GPUs worth of experiments. Uh, as soon
as I figure out how we can get these
ports forwarded correctly, I'm going to
start pulling up graphs. It's
essentially a bunch of different large
scale hyperparameter sweeps. And we are
honing in now on um automating
the compute data trade-off. So basically
automated discovery of for a particular
environment, how much compute versus how
much data can we spend and what is the
shape of that trade-off.
have the meta ray bands. No,
I don't think I would be getting those
either. Yeah.
Oh.
Why?
I I uh I don't have my sunglasses around
here, but like
I don't see the point.
What happened here exactly? I this is
supposed to have a port ported
the future. Oh man. So the number of
photos I take ever is like
I go entire months without taking a
single photo sometimes
I don't know. I don't really see the
appeal.
Um,
I don't want to kill this container to
fix this.
Let me start with the other ones. I
think this one has ports up, right?
Oh, yeah. You know why it does? It's
because a dummy. Um, of course it has
this. This one's not in a container.
Okay, so this actually worked this time.
You see?
I think. Uh,
all right. So, this one here, we can
ignore this.
So, these are all of the runs
that are above 20 score.
And you can see that there are these
stripes because I actually ran six
different uh base configurations.
we actually have a good bit of data
here, right?
Which GPUs are you using? Uh we are
currently for these experiments that I'm
running now. We've done or just ran
overnight total of 12 4090s and 1590
is most of our compute.
buffer has 20 21 GPUs, I believe.
Okay. I mean, we have this one right
now. Let's try this one over here.
Did I do breakout on this one? I think I
did. Yeah.
base advantage of 50. Uh so
for reasonably sized networks, it's
usually like only 10 or 20%. But then
for whatever reason, it can be like four
to five times faster for some wonky
configurations.
So, I have one of them. Um, technically,
do I have one or two?
I believe I have two actually. Yeah, I
have
I actually forget if I have one or two,
but um the one that I use for
experiments at the very least, I do it
specifically to test on the uh the
faster chip.
yeah, this one's breakout.
And this ran all 1200 experiments.
All I do is I change this to breakout.
And then what do we define as a solve?
Like 850.
nothing above
really
You you know what happened here? I bet
you.
No, actually I was gonna say that it was
too slow to uh train in time, but no,
this is just weird.
Yeah, that's just super weird. I don't
know what this is.
Okay, we go back to pong analysis then
for a little bit here. So,
wait, what? We actually have solves at
500k.
I mean, it's probably like eight frame
skip, so four mil, but still that's
wacky.
That actually works.
I mean, I guess according to this,
there's just no compute data trade-off
because you just solve everything with
this one.
Yeah, but FBR we're doing compute data
tradeoff. So, um, frame skip counts as a
data multiplier.
So, if we're trying to figure out what's
the minimum number of steps we can solve
in. All right, let me let me kind of
explain what the expected thing here is.
All right, so the expected thing that
we're looking for, right, is some sort
of graph that's like this.
Or depending on the shape, it could also
be more like this. It could be sharper
or it could be shallower, right? It
could be like this. Um,
and this is saying that we can spend
more compute or we can spend more data
to solve the problem. But what's
happening at the moment is we get
something
if we just draw the line, right? we get
something like this and like this
cuz it's basically it's just like you're
solving the problem quickly no matter
what data scale you use at the moment.
Welcome Jess. We're looking at some runs
from last night.
Um so down and to the left is best,
right? But what is
okay? Let's say that you have points all
along this line, right? Like let's say
that you have a point here, a point
here, a point here, uh a point here,
right? Which of these is better? Is this
point better or is this point better?
The answer is both. They're both Pareto
optimal.
You seem to have more energy. I have had
food.
I uh I realized that if I just if I
tried to end my cut tomorrow night
instead of last night, I one, I wouldn't
have been able to actually take my
pictures and which I did this morning.
Uh and two, I wasn't going to have any
energy for my run either at all.
final weight I got was 160
167.4,
which is down pretty much the full 15.
No, the full 18 pounds I wanted to do.
I have um pictures and like a video to
edit up for the article later today.
I'm still trying to think what to do
with this. How tall? 5'9.
Peak weight was 190.
Um, but you know, like keep in mind this
is not like, oh, I got fat up to 190,
right? This is from lifting. Um,
what did I eat? Not much different from
normal. I like just had my normal dinner
plus some carbs, like an extra pastry
this morning uh with breakfast. It's not
a huge difference. It's just actually
having some some reasonable amount of
carbs.
Let's Let's see if we can like actually
get something out of
Hang on. out of this.
If I do like
well, I don't really do that is the
thing, right? Like
like I've never had a problem
overeating. So, the reason that I did
this cut, right, like this was not just
like, oh, oops, I got fat, right? This
was like I was at the end of a bulk
where I was about to do a normal cut and
then instead of getting to start my cut,
I got put in the hospital on catabolic
steroids. So, I lost 18 pounds in the
hospital of muscle instead of fat.
So, I just got [ __ ]
is what happened.
So anyways, I figured fine, I'm going to
do like a absolutely psychotic cut and
I'm going to lose 18 lbs of not muscle
this time.
Yeah.
Exactly. No, see I'm on the
opposite end FBR where like I have
always been super lean and underweight
my whole life and then I started lifting
a whole bunch, right? So the difficult
part for me is putting weight on, not
getting it off.
So the like it pretty much the only
thing that was ever going to cause this
for me is medical grade catabolic
steroids.
Like otherwise, basically I was going to
have to do maybe like a 10 pound cut at
the end of a pretty heavy bulk and I
would have been just about the same. Um,
yeah.
I don't know. I have a whole article on
this stuff.
proud of the result though.
This is not an easy This was not an easy
block.
Jess, I was freaking tempted for that
exact reason, but those things do kind
of kill you,
which in my mind, that's like the lamest
thing ever, right? We literally have
like super soldier serum. Um, but it
kills you.
Like, tell me that's not just the lamest
thing ever, right?
All right, I'm dumb. I forgot to port
forward
Marvel who was realistic.
I mean,
I don't know.
My hope is eventually we figure out how
to do this without it killing you,
right?
Why the heck is this performing so bad?
What did I do?
I'm literally I have frame skip in here,
don't I?
I literally have frame skip in here.
So uh
huh
biocheml model that is ultimately the
plan
once we have RL like the thing is cuz
bio like biosim has enough of its own
problems right that like you kind of
want all of the RL stuff to just work
before you go and do that. But uh yeah
that is the top thing I ultimately care
about.
hide and seek end making use in
attention model
to make a separate torch file. Uh if you
want to replicate the exact policy then
yes.
Well, I guess if it's in ocean, right,
you just add like the ocean m just have
their own policy within the same file
for now. It depends how you're doing it.
But yeah, you just do a little custom
policy
I know something something really weird
must have
Where should I start? They didn't seem
open source. That's about protein
folding sim.
What do you mean where should I start?
It's a fairly simple like the torch
model is not the hard part of that
project.
Like you literally just slap in any
attention layer. It's not even over time
steps, right? The attention is not over
time steps.
Okay. I mean, so we see the frame skip
thing here. This is expected for the
most part, right?
Okay, so we have our 128
hidden and we even have some samples out
to here. So that's not it.
Why the hell are these sweeps just like
way below where they should be?
This is literally the default samples.
The highest one.
at FBR. You should look at the Madrona
code for the uh Madrona has like a it's
kind of stripped down is the thing their
version of it.
I have the freaking parameters for this
somewhere.
Yeah. I'd help you in more detail, but I
kind of need to stay a little bit
focused on this today because I've got
some carbs back in me, but it's going to
take a few days before I'm back to like,
you know, full capacity. I'm probably
only going to get like um, you know,
two, three focused hours of work on this
today.
And I'd like to actually have some
proper understanding of this
uh by then.
Okay, so we have one thing
that gets
and then without frame skip
2 E7 3 E7
Yeah. So we have stable in 40 million
with no frame skip, right?
So there's no reason that this should be
this stupid.
I mean, it should just be pick your
choice, right?
I feel like dramatically more relaxed
today as well.
I don't know. It's like
I guess it's probably I'm just roughly
back. Not even fully yet, but just more
back to baseline
Well, notice a blrite that's going to
take longer than I gave it budget for.
Just make sure that these things work
though.
My whole feed is just garbage.
Every so often we have some like cool
stuff, but it's just all crap. There's
like very little research on here, which
is ridiculous.
Um, this doesn't seem to actually be
doing it, does it?
I'll have to go see if I missed
anything. What's the curve look like for
this?
It's also possible this is unstable as
heck, right? like,
Yeah, but this thing thinks it's going
to be done faster than it will be.
I guess I also didn't do
have update epochs on it or num mini
batches.
All right. So, I have to compute this,
don't I?
Yeah. Yeah. I'm going to have to like
fiddle with this a few times before I
get something, I'm sure.
But the um
it is important that I have not just
Pong because in my experience, right,
Pong is kind of a toy environment
in the sense that like
stuff if something does better on Pong,
it doesn't necessarily mean it does
better on a lot of stuff, right? If
something works on Pong, it doesn't mean
it actually works. Generally breakout is
the simplest environment for which
usually if it works on breakout it's
pretty good
bug free chess oo
that's cool
I would like there to be chess
environment
chess environment would be very Nice.
I think that's right, isn't it? 512 MS.
We'll see that does anything different.
Be kind of funny if it did.
so it's 512 environments time 64 32k.
All right. I guess we'll see if this
does anything different, right?
And if this finishes correctly, then
this is 240 seconds is 4 minutes. So
that's actually in time.
It's actually expected that it gets
stuck, by the way, at like 400 something
because that's when it clears the first
screen and it has to be able to like hit
the last brick on the first screen.
That's pretty normal for it to like take
a while to break through that plateau.
And there. And now it's into 500.
Yeah.
I mean, we do have successes that are
out here farther with the
reasonable clip,
right?
How many steps would you find a
reasonable dissolve?
uh some massive number.
I'm not care like so to be clear, Jess,
I don't actually care about sample
efficiency for any fixed problem. I care
about solving the problem. I do this
research so that for clients and
problems where it's hard to make the end
fast, we have outs. Um
like typically you have to look at
learning curves
and just like look at the shape of
Enough.
So, we know that there's something screw
with this, right? This one. I'm trying
to think what analysis we do out of
this.
We just keep pushing it to the left.
Yo, why are you using Neptune over WB?
because at least for now it's better.
Their like dashboard system is better.
It's a bit faster even though they're
both super slow. This is I also have
this right. I'm doing my own custom
stuff now as well for my own
experiments. Way faster.
We did
depending actually on whether the other
one finished. We probably did like 3,000
experiments overnight.
I mean, when we're actually ready to
automate the full final set of
experiments, it's going to be 25,000.
Okay, so I just had copied the hypers
wrong. Uh, it turns out you can actually
solve
can actually solve breakout. It's
looking like
in under four minutes with 40 mil steps
without frame Yep.
Yep, that is a full solve right there.
40 mil steps, 3 minutes 30 seconds.
Yeah. No, it's stable. Well, but for
some reason, right, our sweep from
before, this sweep didn't find it. So,
I'm trying to figure out why.
Um, you know, I guess one thing that
does
then what I divide this. So, this is 64.
Let me make sure this still solves.
It should, but I got to check it.
Make sure I didn't break anything.
It is slower and this takes it outside
of the range of what we could have run
but still should be able to do better
than this.
And I am already feeling the fatigue a
little bit. That's crazy.
Nothing good on this damn site anymore,
is there?
X has become a right only medium.
Oh, that is usually doing cool stuff,
right?
Ooh. Okay. If this doesn't work, that'll
be really weird, right?
If this doesn't work, there's a big
problem.
Hopefully,
I'm honestly hoping that this just works
because I'd rather deal with the problem
of why the heck is the sweep not finding
this than the alternative.
If there's something wrong with like the
vectorization back end in some niche
case, that's way worse.
It does change the timings of stuff
though, doesn't it?
I have to regen this graph.
No, but this is fine, right? Yeah, this
is still fine. We're good.
All right. It wasn't that luckily.
Yeah. Okay. So, these are the couple
points that we just ran. So, we can see
that we have like 12,000 or 1,200
freaking experiments and then we just
run a couple and we do better already,
which is ridiculous. Um,
we have 100 mil, we have 40 mil,
I can't think of anything better to do
than just going down the list of
hyperparameters.
Can you?
I don't think so.
what the heck is up with the steps
thing?
Oh, no. That's fine.
So, it literally can't figure out how to
get more than 100 score with this.
That's crazy.
Okay.
I'm trying to figure out how it is that
it could not find this.
Like what's so special about this set
that
the sweep couldn't find it?
Didn't think hard enough.
Well, I definitely didn't think hard
enough over the last week. All right.
I have at least a double-digit number of
brain cells available to me today.
Like I there's nothing here I have
removed from the normal sweeps.
Well, at least now I know this thing is
screwy.
Let me go see what the heck it is that I
ran on uh on the other puffer box.
Pong.
This is Pong.
This is some sort of sweep on pong.
Oh, I know what this thing right.
Yeah, this is
this is 500k
uh step pong. I already know the outcome
of this.
Like I already know that this one works.
Yeah. So, I have it. I just don't have
it implemented for enough stuff uh for
what I'm doing. FBR
It's hot reloading the data file, but
when I change like the fields that need
to be looked at, it doesn't hot reload
That
in ends.
You mean in ends.
Oh.
Um, you could Yeah.
Yeah, the build should be like virtually
instant, but you do have to like rerun
it and stuff. Oh, wait. Run the end
while I'm building. No, you don't. If
you're rebuilding from Python, you're
trolling.
You should be using the build ocean
script
and just doing the dev in pure C.
I can just keep running pong lower and
lower, right?
Yeah,
that one's pretty easy.
I suppose I probably
what probably needs to happen is I need
to rerun this sweep stuff that I'm doing
I probably just need to rerun the data
or the was it the time efficiency sweep
on the good hardware with these new
configs and I'm going to figure out that
like 12 mil was just way too big to
begin with or something, right?
probably what's going to
Okay. I mean, this seems to be running
just fine
alone.
And then
I guess just in general we figure out
what the heck is wrong with our pawn uh
breakout sweeps, right?
I can do this with a multi sweep thing
pretty quick, can I?
probably.
Yeah, I want to see if this can figure
it out.
if this does uh anything relatively
quickly or not.
What?
Well, that's something, right?
Oh, yeah, that's something.
There's some like old data in here as
well, but
Really?
How did I not do this?
Dude, you got to be kidding me.
I really didn't do this on this freaking
machine.
Sucks.
I literally don't know how I missed
that.
Now I'm not going to know the freaking
frame Yep.
So this is actually this is going we can
leave that alone.
Wait, it is in there. Oh, wait, wait,
wait. We got it.
Yeah, we got it. We're good.
All right.
Uh, what?
this is what we're starting to call a
frontier, right?
I mean, we haven't really aggressively
optimized this yet, but like the
frontier we're looking for is this line
here. All right.
Like, this is what we're expecting.
It's just that I expected this line to
be like I expected it to be worse
basically. So, technically, I spent a
few days being confused because I didn't
think we would possibly get results this
good.
Can't be mad about that.
This is actually only a factor of four
off from the Atari 100K because the
Atari 100K is actually Atari 400K.
That's got a nice ring to it.
Solving reinforcement learning with no
data instantaneously.
Pulling yourselves out. We pull
ourselves up by our bootstraps when
we're not even wearing boots.
and actually come to think of it can be
even better than this.
I guess the only assumption I am sort of
making here right is like
I am making a few little assumptions,
but the the assumptions I'm making only
mean that if I drop them later, I can
get even better results. Maybe
So I mean this is like more than 50x
what is this? This is like 50x data
efficiency
over our baseline.
I mean that's
that's pretty good, right?
And this is actually technically even
faster than our baseline, too. This is
just winning.
Oh, yeah. Because this is on the real
hardware, right? This is Yeah, this is
on the actually good hardware.
That's like crazy crazy.
I guess we just win.
I mean, basically what this means,
right, is I was drawing. Let me explain
to you what just happened.
So,
I was trying to draw this like graph
that looks like this, right? But what I
tried to do is I like had some data out
here
and it all kind of looked the same.
So, like I was like,
you know, what the heck, right? This
data like there's no signal in here. But
it turns out that I just expected it to
take way more time steps uh than it
actually takes. And if you go back to
here, you know, you start to see it down
here a little and then it's like flat.
So I just didn't go Whoops.
I didn't go uh all the way out to here.
At least that's what's happened with
Pong.
with breakout. Something's broken.
44 so far.
We'll see if this does any better.
Yeah, I mean it makes it makes sense
though. This actually does make sense
that this happens this way. Okay.
Um, let me think what else we can do
today, folks.
How long have I been live? Only an hour
and a half.
We could do a little bit of work on the
dashboard. I suppose
Yes. So this is what we want, right? is
we want like this basic.
Okay. So, this is this is what it needs
a data frame for.
When maximizing a sweep, is it looking
at the final point for each curve?
Uh, it's looking at the final estimate.
Yeah.
And by default, puffer will run like a
little extra post eval to try to make
that point more accurate.
Uh, I'm not doing this. I'm letting
freaking GPT do this [ __ ] This is like
garbage library.
I'll have to replace it with something
better later.
I'm not really working on the visualizer
as much as I'm like punting on it.
Like anything that's callback based like
this is just trash. All right. Like it
doesn't matter if it's
it doesn't matter like that this thing
produces reasonable graphs and stuff.
Like it actually screws up when you It's
funny but like this code is just trash.
Anything that's like heavily
callbackbased and has callbacks with
decorators is just garbage.
90%.
Wait, it would be I don't know what you
mean. FBR. What are you talking about?
Still not doing it.
Don't like that.
No, I I mean there's nothing that I
could do quickly basically.
As expected, the LM is [ __ ] useless.
Um,
guess this gets me.
Do I seriously have to do it this way?
That's so [ __ ]
You know what? No, I'm not doing that.
That's just dumb. [ __ ] off.
We're not using like at callback
decorator. Screw that.
I don't have Express in here. It just
[ __ ] this LLM.
These models can't code. If you think
they can, you're bad at programming.
Stupid.
Any junior engineer can follow those
instructions. Yeah, the models are super
human.
So dumb. All right, let me figure out a
way to get this thing to be interactive
without me making a total mess of
literally everything.
Um,
These models are just dumb and they just
tempt you to they just tempt you to just
make your codebase worse and worse by
incorporating their dog [ __ ]
Now I'm kind of mad. So I'm just going
to see
uh if I can actually
this
for what format I should put this in for
pandas.
I don't know why this even has to be
freaking pandas like this. There's
almost like No, we're not. You know
what? We're not doing that. That's just
dumb.
Start from scratch with AI.
Uhhuh.
I mean, they're just both so bad.
Like, okay, can like look, it's a
plotting library, right?
Why the hell do I is it immediately like
pandas call back hell like freaking
fancy ass layout? Like why?
Like literally nuke a fly.
So stupid.
I mean, I swear like
if I had to deal with the average
programmer's code all day for my job, I
wouldn't do this. I would go work in a
field that's not completely
inhabited by utter imbecile.
The thing is like good software is so
cool, right? It's like
it's the closest thing we have to
freaking magic.
Bad software is just an abomination.
It's like a monument to human stupidity.
We're going to try this. We're going to
try array of dicks first. See if this
This might be
too slow, but it should be
simple to filter this at least. We'll
see.
We lack the apprentice model wizards
had.
Yes. The imp the ah yes, the well-known
wizards apprentice model.
like a site that was so
AI from management. That's pathetic.
I mean, look, this is literally I'm not
a webdev at all, okay? This site is
freaking HTML,
JavaScript,
and some CSS.
And like the only things that are slow
on here, right, are um like these WASM
beds
cuz there's like a lot of stuff from the
uh these demos, but everything else is
just like chill, right?
It's all you need.
I mean, when I go to like, you know,
like a very professional whatever site
and it like doesn't freaking load
slow as hell and like bloated, it's
okay, whatever.
There's like a list of things that I
would buy, like a very long list of
things given infinite money, and a
Lambo's not even on it.
Um,
how many What
are you meing? Cuz I'm getting
distracted here. Where's that at?
Okay, let's ignore this drop down crap
for a second. All right,
there's a bunch of stuff here. Yeah. But
like this actually works. Cool.
I could just make a bunch of graphs and
not have to deal with this crap, right?
Just check stuff more carefully than you
think you need to. Is all
a lot of the time research you're better
off just like doing something else
rather than doing it tired.
because you're going to cost yourself
more time making mistakes than if you
were to just go like chill or literally
do anything else and then come do it
fresh.
Putting the one before the neighbors
kids drive me [ __ ]
and I like peace and quiet almost to the
point of it being like irrational.
Have you read the Sutton and Sutton and
Bardau book? No, not at all.
You can read that entire book and you'd
like
that's not
that book really doesn't help you do
good RL research.
Yay. Look at that. All right, we can
autogen the hell many plops we want now.
I think we say screw it and we can just
scroll
because like otherwise like look they've
reimplemented HTML in Python because
stupid. I'm not wasting my time [ __ ]
with that.
Like that's just dumb.
Look guys, we wrapped HTML so you can
write HTML in Python instead of writing
HTML.
No,
we're not doing that.
Are you good at leak code? Nope.
I would fail like uh I would fail a
screen that literally 18-year-old
freshman me would pass
and be amazing at le code and be a
terrible programmer.
I think we just add like a couple basic
things here that let us do our next
block of analysis and we come back to
more of this later. So like
I do here.
Oh.
Honestly, without knowing anything else,
like knowing you drive a Lambo doesn't
like that's not a positive signal
at all.
Okay. So, this is this is nicer here,
right?
Yeah, but that's my point. It's a status
thing and it's a stupid status thing,
right?
we don't actually get like the
sensitivity
Why do you have headphones right now?
Neighbors kids were being annoying.
They went in though.
Yeah, because this is missing out right
on
I guess we could What happens if I
change this
the steps?
Oh, you know what? This has
this has like weirdly mixed data in it.
Hang on.
This has like weird mixed data, right?
Yeah.
Let's do anything over a million is
going to be just outed
you release any article about world
models? I released an article about my
findings that include a little bit of
world models, but mostly about on verse
off policy, which is the more important
distinction that's applicable as well on
X.
So the key problem right they let you do
on policy RL on the world model which is
really good
but the world models are really
expensive to train which is not Good.
for world models. The only problem is
yeah, so world model has um if you think
of offpaul as having the problem of it
being a weaker algorithm. So you needing
to invest more compute.
World models let you use the compute
efficient algorithm, but then you have
to train the world model, which is
really clunky.
So basically like
it seems that there's always going to be
a gap between the amount of compute you
need to spend for on and off Paul.
Yeah, I sent uh actually Finn and Sam.
They should have uh I sent them a nice
drone.
Yeah, this is way nicer. Look at this.
We've got our full data tradeoff here.
way better plots.
It's a big upgrade.
What about this thing? This should have
had enough data.
Got up to 640, which is better than
before, but it's um I mean, this has had
a lot of time to run experiments and it
hasn't found a solve yet, which is kind
of dumb.
Okay. Well, we found
we got this
This is a nice little upgrade to our
visualization generally. So, let's push
this
now. Can I figure out what is wrong with
the rest of our stuff?
We can actually go run this right on the
other tiny box, Then
here the solve runs
all the way down to 3 mil total.
There's learning rate
mini batches hidden size
stuff in here
frame skips.
Cool.
This is real data, right?
Oh, and we can also drop the uh the bad
filter,
right? This is why we're not getting any
data.
Cool. Now we actually get lots of data
here, right?
Here's our learning rate. Here's our
number of mini batches.
Hidden size we have over a larger range.
And we've got frames skip. Cool.
Range
and is a better dashboard now.
Completed.
What's up with this guy? H
Why are we at a max of 643?
What I want to know.
this is cost in score actually is what
this is.
Why is it not finding
like we literally know there's a good
run in here, right?
Is there any crazy params in here that
would be hard for it to learn?
Like I don't think so. Right.
weird.
Very weird.
down sample like
go figure.
What did I do to get this thing to
actually work?
I go pick
Well, I've been streaming for about 3
hours and I have other stuff to do
today. I've got limited energy. So,
here's what I'm going to do.
We've got a new palm sweep running now,
right?
We got a new palm sweep going. Let me
make sure it's still good.
I'm going to go write on my article for
a bit and then I will be back.
Maybe I might do a short thing tomorrow,
but probably like Monday or Tuesday.
I got some travel set up for next week
as well. But this is going to be the
main project. It's a lot of like little
fiddly experiment things. Uh once we
actually get this dialed in though, this
is going to start moving very quickly
and we're going to get a lot of cool
results really fast. So for uh folks
watching, thank you for tuning in.
Buffer.ai for all the things you want to
help me out for absolutely free. Star
the GitHub. You're interested in getting
involved, join the Discord and follow me
on X for more RL content, including all
of my guides and articles.
Thank you and see you around. Enjoy your
weekend.